hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
fast and automated tsa based
multiplexed immunofluorescent on lab fat
research i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by lunafore
to learn more visit them at lunafore.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions
you may have during the presentation to
do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker
alexander curran
an application development team leader
at luna 4
technologies alexander welcome you may
now begin
your presentation
thank you and welcome everyone so today
i'm going to present you the general
overview of the microfluidic technology
developed at luna 4
and the auto stainer labs app we're
going to go through
a specific application of lab set which
is the automated tsa based multiplexing
and see how to optimize the assay on
tonsil tissue
and then we're going to see a method for
easy transfer
of those optimized protocols to
cancerous tissue
and in this specific case a study on
non-small cellular carcinoma
at the end we will have a live q a and
as mentioned before we will answer the
questions received during the
presentation
so um luno4 core technology is based on
a microfluidic chip
called mtp for microfluidic tissue
processor
it is used for tissue analysis assays
like immunofluorescence or
immunohistochemistry
the chip is equipped with a series of
microfluidic channels
used for reagent delivery it is clamped
against a standard glass slide that
makes
a closed chamber over the tissue sample
this technology is called a fast fluidic
exchange
for ffx
so the pressure driven reagent flows uh
directly almost instantaneously in the
chamber
the liquid exchange is very rapid
between the steps
a heating element placed just below the
slide
allows precise temperature control at
any time as well as rapid temperature
changes
the perfect ceiling between the chip and
the
in the slide offers a controlled
environment to the tissue
with multiple benefits staining times
are
much faster due to reduced uh diffusion
times
in the chamber you there is a more
uniform staining over the tissue
the rapid and high temperature epitope
retrieval are made possible
while preventing region evaporation and
preserving the tissue
this technology was born at the swiss
federal
institute of technology in lausanne and
had been widely validated across
a number of studies and publications
we have demonstrated that running
microfluidic-based immunofluorescence
essays with short incubation times
we could better quantify the fortune
signal from the tissue thanks to the
avoidance of saturation
we could even classify ambiguous her2
status of breast carcinomas
into fish positive and negative basing
ourselves on the quantification
of our fluorescent herb2 staining
we have also shown that we can obtain
extremely rapid chromogenic and
fluorescent stainings
on different markers on both ffp and
frozen samples
additionally we've shown that dna and
rna can be preserved during the
stainings performed with our instrument
and the samples can be further utilized
after staining for ngs
with our technology we can also run fish
assays and targeted rna expression
and finally in this presentation i'd
like to introduce you
to the use of our technology and our
instrument lab set
to perform term-made signal
amplification based multiplexing assays
in combination with the opal kit from
bakoya
the mtp chip is integrated
in an automated device that is called
labset research
regions are simply loaded in eight
standard eppendorf and buffers are
stored in
four falcon tubes the chip
is placed in a staining chamber
maintained by a lid
ready to be clamped against a slide
another important microfluidic element
of the system
is the distribution chip it acts as a
gateway
between the reservoirs and the chamber
and ensures the proper control of the
flow
towards the tissue reagents
are pushed from the reservoir towards
the distribution system
from where their dispense is controlled
to the staining chamber once the region
is finished
reagents are simply discarded to a
liquid waste
after having tested and proven the
efficiency of the
mtp on single markers immunofluorescence
and hemoglosochemistry we decided to
move towards
multiplexing assays there is an
important drive towards multiplexing
techniques as the context of
personalized medicine
requires even higher number of markers
to be investigated
in order to build better diagnostics
multiplexing immunofluorescence and
immunohistochemistry in particular
are interesting as they allow for
simultaneous marker detection
while keeping the information of
morphological context
that is especially relevant in the study
of the interaction between the tumor and
its micro
environment so the method
chosen uh to do immuno versions
multiplexing on lap set
is the tyramid signal amplification tsa
this technique allows simultaneous
marker detection on the same tissue
the working principle is the following
so on
your first antigen of interest you would
detect using a primary antibody that you
would bind with a secondary antibody
conjugated to an enzyme here a
horseradish peroxidase
that in turn will catalyze the reaction
of
a tyramid for conjugate that binds
to the tuberosine residues at the
antigen site
before moving to the next marker
detection the antibodies need to be
removed
by application of heat on the tissue
this step is called illusion
the covalent bound between the rosin and
the teramide
ensures that the signal stays on the
tissue
even after the elution step
then next subsequent markers can be
detected using the same method
but ingest by applying a different flow
for
this can be repeated for all uh the
markers in
a panel and once
all the termites are bound the slide is
ready for imaging
tsa kit chosen for this project
is the widely used opel kit from aquaria
biosciences
and the goal was to adapt these reagents
to the lab set system
we use the seven color manual detection
uh
for six markers plus uh conscious
staining
uh with floor fours uh of excitation
wavelengths
ranging from 520 to 690 nanometers
so our objective is to automatize a full
six plex using the opal kit
and while the pre-processing
meaning the peripheral departurization
rehydration of the tissue
as well as imaging will still be
done outside a lab set the machine will
take on
all the steps that are directly related
to the staining itself
starting with the heat induced epitope
retrieval
pruning blocking primary antibody
secondary antibody
and the tsa itself then illusion
all the steps being repeated in the
number of times corresponding to the
detected markers and finally country
staining
the essay development process was
organized around four main axes
the first one the single plex
optimization
for each marker with the objective to
reach
good and repeatable performance for
every marker individually
the second axis is the uniformity
optimization
with the aim to obtain homogeneous
signal levels over the tissue
even over large sections and then the
antibody elusion optimization
to make the heat induced strip off
reach complete antibody removal between
cycles
while preserving the tissue morphology
at the same time
and finally the multiplexing part
bringing
all the individual optimized elements in
one multiplexing assay
and build a fast and efficient workflow
on the machine
the six markers selected for the panel
are typical immuno markers
fox 3 pdm 1 pd1 cd68 cd8
plus pen ck for cytokeradians
the optimization of the sa was done on
ffpe
sections of human tone cells a positive
control tissue for those markers
so first axis of the tonsil optimization
project
singleplex optimization
so the sa was directly developed on lab
set
with a goal to ensure high staining
quality
while keeping a reduced execution time
the parameters could be directly
adjusted from the software interface of
labs that research
and the parameters that were
available for us to
to play with were the antigen
refrigerant so both
temperature and pressure settings the
regent incubation
here again temperature duration and
region flow optimization and finally
primary antibody and substrate titration
just like in any regular essay
the image acquisition was done on a
mantra imaging station
and the inform software was used for
image analysis
when using the opel detection system
acquisitions need to be post process
in particular the signal signal needs to
be deconvoluted
to separate the information compare
corresponding to each opel flow for
we built a spectral library prior to
this study and used n-form
to do unmixing as well as cell
segmentation of the tissue for further
analysis
and quantification
the single pack staining optimization
resulted in bright and
specific signal for all the markers with
high normalized mean intensity
of balanced value across the six markers
the results are here displayed in
software right field view which is the
inform pathology view
for each marker the variability of the
protocol was assessed
on nine consecutive slides the single
plex repeatability
showed less than 15 percent of the
signal of signal variability
underlining the effective automation of
vocals on that system
now the uniformity axis uniformity of
the fluorescent signal is an important
feature
of an optimized protocol that can be
challenging
to obtain some time especially on large
tissue sections
labsat offers some interesting
functionalities
that help obtaining a better uniformity
when using a standard incubation of the
reagent on the tissue
depending on the method that is applied
this can lead to an
in homogeneity in the signal level
across your tissue
lab set allows for an active control of
the flow during the incubation
the liquid motion in the chamber can be
controlled at any time
ensuring a more uniform distribution of
the reagent over the tissue
this method called dynamic incubation
increased significantly the level of
uniformity
of stainings done on lab set
we assess the efficiency of dynamic
incubation
by uh looking at the signal gradient on
slides incubated in a standard fashion
versus
the slides that were applying the
dynamic incubation method
and we saw that over one centimeter of
tissue
the signal drop was reduced down to six
percent
uh when using dynamic incubation
compared to 30 percent with a standard
incubation
which represents a significant
improvement in uniformity
the third axis of the project is the
elusion optimization
the role of the elusion step is to
ensure a proper removal
of the primary secondary antibody
complex
between two marker detections
the method that we use on labsad is
simply
applying a high heat to the tissue
to assess the efficiency of this elusion
method
we compared a reference stain slide
versus an eluted slide which simply
consists
in applying the illusion process after
primary antibody and secondary antibody
incubations before re-incubating with
secondary antibody
and the substrate if the illusion is
efficient
no signal should be observed on the
eluted slide
the illusion efficiency was defined as
the signal removal rate
the solution efficiency was tested for
all the markers in the panel
and signal removal rate was over 99
for uh all the six of them which was
considered
as a performance illusion
since our elusion process uh involves
high
temperature it was important to test
that the repetition of those heat cycles
would have limited impact on tissue
morphology
so we tested a different repetition
numbers
of those heating cycles for uh three
different
uh singleplex and we could observe no
apparent degradation
uh of the the resulting staining
due to the repetition of the illusion
nuclear morphology
extracellular metrics and epitope
detections
were preserved
the last part of this tonsil
optimization
it's the full six clicks to say and
our goal is to build an efficient
workflow with a
minimum number of user interactions
so the teacher preprocessing and region
preparation is handled by the user
then then that then has to load all the
elements
on the machine lab set then perform
fully automatically free marker
detections
then due to limited number of reservoirs
a user intervention
is required made protocol in order to
load the regions needed for the last
three cycles
after what the protocol can be resumed
and finished
finally the slide can be retrieved at
the end of the protocol
mounted and imaged
the final result is a semi-automated
sixplex plus counter-staining
that can be achieved in four hours and
12 minutes
the full essay showed adequate marker
detection compared to the single plex
optimization
the conclusion of this first part
of the study is that the lab site offers
a tsa based multiplexing approach with
high signal intensity for each marker
an adequate signal uniformly across the
tissue section
an efficient antibody illusion with over
99
of single removal for the six markers
while preserving the tissue morphology
and the epitopes at the same time all
this with a
high level of consistency
so we're now moving to the second part
of the study which is the transfer
of the multiplexing essay on using lab
set
on a different tissue type a cancer
teacher so multiplexing
assay optimized and tonsil can sometimes
not be completely
adapted to other specific tumor sections
because of different marker expression
patterns
or sometimes tissue specificities like
different structures
different levels of photoversions etc
the question we ask here is
is this tonsil optimized protocol
applicable to my cancer tissue samples
we approached this with a three-step
transfer strategy
first we applied the tonsil optimized
protocol
directly to our cancer sample
then we evaluated the performance and
defined
what needed to be re-optimized and
finally we modified
protocol parameters in order to reach
the desired performance
i'm going to we're going to go through
um a small case study on non-smoking
lung carcinoma old tumor
and tma sections our objective is to
reach
an acceptable performance on this tissue
in a
minimum number of optimization step
because
our aim is to avoid the re-optimization
from zero
labset offers the flexibility of
optimization
and some important parameters can be
readjusted
directly from the software interface
like the antenna treatment temperature
the incubation times but also uh
protocols are modular you can add uh
extra steps like blockings
quenching et cetera and of course you
can always play with the
standard element of an essay like region
titrations
so the first phase of the transfer
strategy
we apply the the tonsil optimized
protocol directly
on known smart cell lung carcinoma
samples
ih stainings of the corresponding
tissues are shown
here as references for marker expression
and we could observe that the direct
application of the protocol
on this particular tissue showed lower
intensity levels than expected
for all the markers compared to what we
had on tonsil
which indicates that re-optimization
might be needed
so we applied uh consecutively two
simple
protocol adjustments the first one was
to increase
the antigen retrieval temperature of the
assay
and the second one was to increase opal
540 uh
concentration opal 540 is the terminate
that
termite that we associated with the cd8
and this was enough to rescue the signal
levels and to show appropriate
detections for
uh all the markers
we then apply this reoptimize six flex
to
nsclc tissue microarray in order to
assess the protocol on various
expression patterns
and here the re-optimized protocol
should appropriate detection
of all the markers on on those
tma cores comparably to the standard ihg
reference
various pattern of expression could be
detected similarly to the ihd reference
using this re-optimized protocol
and the total time of the sa remain
remain
unchanged compared to the tonsil
optimized protocol
staying at 4 hours and 12 minutes
so as a conclusion lapsed offers the
possibility to run a six flex seven
color sa
in a timely manner with high quality
results
both in terms of signal uniformity strip
of efficiency
and morphology preservation the tonsil
optimized protocol could be transferred
to lung cancer tissue for the same assay
duration
and the protocol transfer process was a
simple
two-step adaptation
i am now happy to answer your questions
thank you so much for that presentation
alexander
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions
coming in from our audience members
our first question what is the maximum
thickness of the samples
that can be placed in the microfluidic
chamber
well so we are working typically
with the ffp tissue sections that are
ranging between two micrometers and five
micrometers thickness and we
have tested up to 10 micrometers without
any issues so
usually that's what we recommend we
want to avoid going higher than 10
micrometers
thank you very much and is the antigen
retrieval automated
and performed on the device
well yes so the all the steps
of the staining uh starting from antenna
retrieval are
taken on by lap sets so it all starts uh
after slide the peripheralization
and everything is taken on by left lapse
that stainer
and everything happens within the
microfluidic chamber
thank you so much alexander arnold are
the
primary antibody used in commercially
is that available
um yes so labsat is an
open platform and it's basically
compatible with
every commercially available regions or
kit so for this study
in particular we have used off-the-shelf
primary antibodies and for multiplexing
tsa
assays we have been used commercially
available monoclonal antibodies
and have you tested this with other
non-opal
tsa reagents
yes we did we tested the
uh thermo super boost tsa kit
um which gave good results uh and
what was interesting is that the
protocol that we had developed for
uh the opal kit was uh
quite easily adaptable for this other
detection kit
thank you alexander and i want to thank
our live audience these are such great
questions
coming in what other applications
are thinking of are you thinking of to
develop on the lab set
instrument alexander
um so well first i think we
are thinking about increasing the
potentialities of the
multiplexing tsa applications so
we would like to increase the number of
markers that you could detect using uh
tsa techniques on lab sets so
we are currently working on a proof of
concept to go
up to eight markers at a time on the
same slide
uh while at the same time offering more
options
in flexibility and template adaptation
like more incubation times or different
temperatures and at the same time on
in parallel i think we are also working
on completely different applications
so we would like to adapt the platform
to uh the sequential immune fluorescence
techniques
so sequences of regular
primary secondary flu labeled antibodies
with imaging vocals in between
each staining which is a technique that
can enable to reach much higher plex
than
multiplexing tsh so this is currently
under investigation
thank you so much now could you scan the
stained slides
on the other digital scanners and are
there any specific
requirements for this um
well yes so labsat performs all the
staining steps
uh uh off the procol and everything
uh that's related to imaging
has to be done outside of the lab set
so i would say that it's compatible with
any microscope that
is equipped with the right multispectral
camera
so for instance here uh for this
uh opal essay we used the uh
okoyas mantra um and
the image analysis by inform
for single unmixing but
it has to be compatible with the
detection kit
and the method that is applied on lab
set
thank you so much now how would you best
use
the lab sat given that it's a single
slide stainer
so laptop research is not a high
throughput instrument
it's an instrument for
low throughput needs for precious
samples
or for single shot antibody optimization
you could also use it as a workflow
support
as a complement to other high throughput
instruments
for instance you could use it to test
new samples
uh in parallel of while other stainers
uh are busy um you could also
use it for urgent uh stainings because
um speed of the assay remains the the
main asset
but in general i would say that labs at
research is more
suited to for projects where it's not
necessary to run dirty slide
at a time rather to obtain results fast
and also if used if you're
looking for a high standing homogeneity
on samples where it is difficult to
achieve
thank you so much alexander and thank
you again for our audience
we have such great questions and we have
time for some more
how does the time of multiplex staining
compare to larger
multi-slide stainers
so uh for a typical six flicks essays
um that can be found in the literature
um so very broadly used
like a bone derricks uh usually has a
turnaround time
in the range of 12 13 hours uh
which would be the same for the deco
auto stinger plus i would say 12 to 13
hours um
so here in this study we could run the
the
a single slide in in four hours and 30
minutes so
yeah if you're if you're looking just
and turn around
times uh yeah it's i would say it's
three three hour and thirty thirty
minutes against uh 12 hours
thank you so much now could tsa be used
for
calculation analysis
um yeah so in this type of assays or at
least
uh with what we could see on lab set
research
um you can it's an interesting technique
for that
um first because you can detect multiple
markers at the time
also because you can achieve
sub-cellular precision
but for quantization analysis you have
to make sure
that the sa is correctly optimized
especially regarding crosstalk so you
have to make sure
that spectral unmixing
is properly done that you do not get
bleed through from other markers or the
channels
so a good way for that is beforehand of
the optimization you
uh could make sure to allocate marchers
um that are supposed to collocalize
to spectrally distinct flow force that
could be a way to go for
politicalization analysis thank you so
much now is the image analysis
automatedly with the inform software
um so for the so
we use the inform software for image
analysis
and this software uh features um
many um different applications for uh
image analysis so
uh ranging from spectral and mixing to
split the raw image into different
channels to cell segmentation
and uh cellular population
classification so
there the software has a whole image
analysis pipeline that you can use to
uh interpret your results
thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions
alexander is it how how do you optimize
the ratio
of six or multi markers after each
marker is validated
so there is some transition to make from
single marker optimization to the
multiplex optimization so
basically what you want to make sure is
that you do not perform differently uh
when you're in the multi-marker staining
compared to the single marker staining
so it is very important to make sure
that your sbr hasn't changed that you do
not have
a bleed through from other markers in
your single marker channels and
we so tsa is uh known for uh
such challenges so it's uh very
important to make sure that you do not
mask
the detection of uh your markers
uh with the detection of previously
stained markers so
of course there is a comparison of
signal-to-background ratio to make
between the single marker stainings and
the multi-marker stainings
thank you so much now have you tried
staining
to an ctc circulating tumor cells
um so staining in
cdcs or in general on
cells cell samples so it's it's not
something that we
have tested yet and it's not something
that
we consider is compatible with the
current multiplexing tsa
template on website it's of course
something that
we'll keep in mind for future
development
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
do you have any ideas to increase
even more the homogeneity of the
staining could you imagine to increase
the flow speed in one side of the chip
well so it's um so with the oscillating
the dynamic incubation technique it's um
already we could already reach good
homogeneity levels but of course
it's something we seek to continuously
improve
um so now we are uh looking to
different ways of increasing homogeneity
in the chamber rather than
floor-related techniques so it's
uh still very early stage in the
development but
something like
temperature-induced diffusion or other
techniques to enhance diffusion
are currently being studied
thank you so much alexander and actually
we have time for a couple of more
our audience is so great we still have
questions coming in
is it good for the brain tissue is our
next question
so i would say you could follow so for
you could follow the same approach that
we
had for a lung in the sense that you
would need to first see
uh how does our standard pro co behave
on your particular sample and then
establish
what in what way you could tweak the
initial
standard focal to make it fit to your
brain tissue
there i would say that
for brain you might want to remake sure
that
uh first your that your tissue thickness
is compatible with the device
and then that you uh have a way to
control the
outer fluorescence of your tissue so for
that it's totally feasible to
implement an autofluorescence uh
quenching step
in the and add it to the standard
multiplexing tsa protocol is
something that we have tested and that
would be feasible here
and alexander what is advantage then
lake uh leica's um multi-staining bond
rx
yeah so of course um so i don't think
you could
directly compare those two devices
because like uh bonarix is
a 30 slides uh uh stainless here we are
talking about
labs research which is a single slide uh
stainless
i would say that uh in general for
high throughput applications so like
bone eric's remains the
the standard but if you're looking for
a device that has very low turnaround
time
if you have only a few pressure samples
to
sustain and you want to move fast in
your project and optimization
then labs that can offer you uh
results in a very timely manner and i
think that's the main
the main asset uh compared to like it
also to other
available devices
thank you so much now did you
try to use a nine flex update recent
aqua system on the tissue sample
um yes so we we tried that on website
um so it's still in in in development so
it's
not commercially available yet as a
template
on labs research but the the first test
um showed very uh promising results and
it works uh really well
um so we were really satisfied with how
uh
reproducible consistent it was converted
to the initial six flex
optimization that we run with the the
the old the koya kit
alexandra thank you again for this great
presentation today
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
um well i would say that the as a
take-home message
the main assets of labs research
regarding multiplexing tsa essays it's
the
instrument versatility it's a very open
platform
you can use off-the-shelf regions you
can adapt it
to your own detection kit
it's also very easy to re-optimize your
your the standard protocol to
adapt it to your sample to adapt it to
your experimental plan
and once this is done then uh
you can take advantage of a left set
main value which is very short staining
time
and and high quality results
alexander thank you again for your
presentation and for your important
research
and we'd also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
luna4 for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrints will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care stay safe
bye-bye thank you very much